si la crise sanitaire liée aux qu'ovide
19 s'est rapidement transformée en
véritable crise économique pour de
nombreux français il faut croire
qu'aujourd'hui certains décident de
profiter de la situation pour se refaire
c'est du moins ce que l'on peut penser
quand on constate les prix pratiqués par
certains laboratoires conservant les
fameux tests pcr
si aujourd'hui tout le monde est invité
à se faire tester le plus souvent
possible pour éviter la transmission du
virus dans un premier temps ces tests
devaient être accessible à tous et
gratuitement sauf que voilà
avec plus d'un million de tests réalisés
chaque semaine en france les
laboratoires d'analysés sont tout
bonnement dépasser files d'attentes
interminables rendez-vous repoussé de
plusieurs semaines retard sur la
délivrance des résultats la situation
est préoccupante de fait certains
laboratoires ont décidé de servir les
plus offrants en proposant des résultats
en 24 à 48 heures contre la somme de 96
euros un prix incompréhensible alors
même que le coût réel d'un tel geste
serait de 54 euros
pourtant cette pratique est totalement
illégale surtout que certains
laboratoires se font rembourser les
tests par la sécurité sociale et aux
proches très l'ensemble de l'argent
récolté alors selon vous nous arrêtons
sur les tests
ouais c'est vrai que ça alors ça je
voulais en parler ce soir parce que
c'est inadmissible
tout le monde a bien nous on va pas
parler du coc vite tout ça on n'est pas
dedans mais là le test a en france s'ils
coûtent 73 euros 59 en moyenne en
allemagne 50 euros en italie 59 et en
espagne entre 30 et 45 euros
on est les plus chers et il rapporte 30
% à peu près si les factures 73 euros et
ça leur coûte 50 euros environ
donc ça fait à peu près de 30 % de
rentabilité c'est vrai que les gens
crient au scandale et maintenant il ya
ce nouveau truc on peut payer plus cher
ouais maintenant et pour avoir les
résultats plus vite compris là ça
devient n'importe quoi franchement il
s'est pas laissée pas les labos qui
arnaquent les gens c'est les jo arnaque
tout le monde sait que les meilleurs
accès la situation est tellement
anxiogène y en a qui veulent pas
attendre parce qu'il ya des gens qui
sont prioritaires femmes et thèze et
quand t'es pas prioritaire tu veux pas
faire un test va attendre plusieurs
semaines et donc un équivalent seront
les fers but à la pêche mais là non pas
rentrer dans mon cas on avec le docteur
christophe prudhomme merci médecin
urgentiste porte parole de l'association
des médecins urgentistes de france
docteur mine de rien les gens vous
comprenez que les gens deviennent foule
ils disent ça veut dire quand on est
riche on peut savoir plus vite si on est
atteint d'une maladie
et quand on est pauvre et ben on doit
rester comme ça on doit dire on doit
attendre le premier problème c'est cette
désorganisation le premier responsable
c'est quand même le gouvernement qui a
mis en place un système qui pour nous
médecins n'est pas utile si on dépense
beaucoup d'argent pour rien certes trois
quatre jours pendant le rendez-vous
trois jours trois quatre jours pendant
leurs résultats au but de mu ou vous
êtes plus contagieux donc ça sert à rien
c'est ça le problème donc on a on est
dans une situation et moi ma première
inquiétude aujourd'hui c'est qu' on
puisse est testé le matin avoir le
résultat le soir c'est ainsi on est
effectivement infecté contagieux on
puisse se confiner pendant sept jours
ça c'est le premier problème le deuxième
problème voyez moi qui m'inquiète
aujourd'hui la polémique chaleur ont eu
ce soir on fait la polémique sur les
masques un soin en fait la polémique sur
les tests
le problème aujourd'hui la première
polémique ces cas lorsqu'on a pour
l'instant quelques dizaines de malades
en plus en partie en réanimation
le gouvernement n'a pas profité des
quatre mois la de répit pour qu'on
puisse avoir les moyens à l'hôpital sert
le nombre de lits suffisant pour
accueillir les malades qui arrivent
aujourd'hui qu'ils seront encore plus
nombreuses
on sait pas comment sera l'hiver et ça
c'est l'inquiétude c'est à dire que on
est dans une situation où d'abord il ya
une perte de confiance des patients la
population est ce parce que stigmatiser
les gens qui viennent pour avoir un test
parce que ils veulent prendre l'avion et
on leur demande c'est obligatoire pour
monter dans l'avion à voir le test va
pas les stigmatiser
la question c'est qu'il faut qu'il ait
une politique cohérente à qui faut-il
faire des tests et qu'on puisse les
faire surtout très rapidement et le
problème aujourd'hui c'est que on a des
tests qui sont les tests salivaires qui
sont un petit peu moins performant que
ces fameuses lettres avec les pavillons
dans le nez sauf que on a le résultat
très rapidement donc alors entre
l'efficacité absolue et puis les tests
un petit peu moins performant il
faudrait qu'on a une stratégie qui soit
adaptée parce qu'aujourd'hui vous savez
là le problème c'est que si on n'est pas
capable ça c'est un gilet pare balles
d'accord mais ça gilet pare balles avec
quelques trous mais c'est sa recontre ce
qu elle plus efficace c'est isolement
depuis que l'humanité existe quand il ya
des gens contagieux on les isole alors
soit de manière volontaire soit de
manière autoritaire vous savez quand il
y avait effectivement les lépreux on
l'aimé on laissait pas entrer dans la
ville sur vielleux nazareth
quand il y avait la peste on laissait
pas rentrer donc là le problème
aujourd'hui c'est que mais on l'a repris
une activité normale d'ailleurs la sauce
platon porte pas de mars le new bond
avant parce que dans certains métiers
il faut comprendre que entre
l'obligation absolue mais porter le
masque dans la rue là quand je vais
sortir alors qu'à quasiment personne je
me prends une amende si je l'est pas
alors qu'en milieu professionnel où
c'est là où il ya plus de contamination
pour des raisons objectives terre
vouloir parler avec le masque un les
gens ils zappent et nous fermer la télé
donc il ya des raisons objectives pour
travailler différemment en limitant les
risques c'est à dire qu'on a pris les
mesures donc il faut que les gens voient
prennent confiance dans ce qui est
proposé par le gouvernement et là ce qui
nous inquiète nos médecins
c'est cette défiance et si cette
défiance persiste quand on va avoir le
vaccin
comment on va faire bien sûr avec une
catastrophe voyez sur la le problème
c'est qu'on est face à un gouvernement
qui fait tout pour que la défiance
augmente pour qu'effectivement y ait des
théories complotistes extérieur qu
émerge sur facebook et rit face que
quand vous dites
avec les gens qui sont convaincus qu'ils
soient arnaquer par le gouvernement vous
avez beau leur argent a mené les
arguments ils ne croient plus à rien on
peut pas discuter
alors alors alors là on parle moins de 7
ans c'est vrai que les gens là tout le
monde même ceux que voilà qui s'y
intéressent d'animation vous intéressé à
ça mais c'est vrai que les tests c'est
n'importe quoi quand on peut passer d'un
test à 50 euros à 100 euros à 80 euros
si on va voir le résultat plus vite là
aujourd'hui les gens deviennent fous il
dit c'est que cela veut dire quoi ça
veut dire si j'ai pas de sous je peux
pas me faire tester rapidement je peux
pas voir mon résultat rapidement en
chine c'est le business des tests - qui
me fait à huy pour la france vous voyez
j'ai fait le tour de plusieurs labos
aujourd'hui mais il ya des centaines de
personnes certaines paniqué parce
qu'elles disent mais je suis claqué je
suis persuadée d'être malade j'en ai
pour des heures juste de contaminer les
ans je n'aurai pas les résultats
la course à l'argent 100 euros pour
aller plus vite
heureusement c'est illégal les labos
arrêté mais il voulait faire de l'argent
mais a cédé l'étions avant les labos
arrêté mais ce qui est ce qu'ils vont
être sanctionnés mais j'espère prenez
vous prenez une abarth quand vous mangez
votre poche chocolat dans la rue ouais
si vous vous rebellez vous allez passer
au tribunal pour rébellion contre agent
de la force publique et le lapin là ils
ont dit ah ben on le fera plus et puis
est-ce qu'ils vont avoir des sanctions
j'aimerais bien qu'ils aient des
sanctions y compris des sanctions
financières le privé des sanctions
financières qui fasse que ça soit
négatif
pour l'instant j'ai pas entendu le
ministre tout à leur parler de sanctions
d'autres c'est l'amour mais c'est non
mais avoir des tales de tels écarts
c'est un prix c'est incroyable on n'est
pas non mais ils ont absolument pas
arrêter c'est dire que moi j'ai enquêté
au genre déjà fait trois labos
évidemment je veux pas donner les noms
dans trois arrondissements différent de
paris on m'a proposé trois prix au
dessus de 100 euros pour me donner un
test de vol peuvent redonner le plus
gros de l'ailé nous est donné pour le
ministre les sanctionne suis pas une
balance et je n'annoncerai la haye mais
en tout cas tu dises est décédé sur
l'assurance maladie grande roue demande
l'assurance maladie vous demande quand
vous êtes victime de ce type d' arnaque
bonne signalé civique un citoyen a
accusé de larnaca sur rooney l'a dit
ouais ça tombe un week-end doctor web
établiront des professionnels on parle
de théâtre et rd ce test
alors je sais que je encore mais quand
le docteur ou tard il faisait les tests
qui avaient débuté que de 250 300 mètres
que tout le monde lui tomber dessus et
les docteurs en premier
cameron mais le problème c'est qu'il est
était gratuit les docteurs ou sur la
gueule et on le prenait pas ce qu'ils
testent et augmentant de l'union il ya
autant de clients que nos lecteurs
voilà donc la question c'est pas de
stigmatiser telle docteur ou tel autre
voyez le président du conseil
scientifique il a dit autant de bêtises
que raul tu la question ces coquilles
havas by women mais il faut un certain
moment donné il ya des choses bien
qu'ils sont dites et les choses alors
bien ce moment